germany is marking 80 years since the
nazi invasion of the soviet union
the surprise attack on june 22 1941
would become the biggest and bloodiest
front in world war
ii and end in nazi germany's complete
destruction
by the end of the war an estimated 27
million soviet citizens
had died including 14 million civilians
from the beginning operation barbarossa
was the
as the invasion was called was conducted
as a war of annihilation
the germans also treated soviet
prisoners of war extremely brutally they
were executed starved or died on forced
marches
from the front lines the nazis took some
5.7 million soviet prisoners of war
over the course of four years it's
estimated that more than three million
soviet pows died
making them one of the largest groups of
nazi victims
and germany's president has been marking
that sombra anniversary here in
berlin frankfurter steinmeier attended a
ceremony
at the german russian museum in the
capital
in his speech steinmeier addressed
criticism from former soviet republics
like
ukraine and belarus that their millions
of victims in world war ii were
neglected
by germany in their commemoration
activities
president steinmeier warned that acts of
remembrance i have not carried out
carefully could themselves lead
to new divisions
i am very concerned that the painful
history we are remembering today
is increasingly becoming a source of
alienation
in itself
about the different perspectives of a
historical event
well such an exchange is rejected
entirely
and history can be rewritten to serve as
an instrument
for new conflicts and new forms of
resentment
that we must not allow history to be
weaponized
germany's president frankfurt are
speaking there and i'm now joined by dw
political correspondent
nina haser to talk about this nina
steinmeier seems to be saying there has
not been enough awareness
of the crimes committed against the
population of former soviet
republics like ukraine or belarus what
does he mean
well he said in his speech he gave an ex
a very personal example that growing up
as a young boy in western germany he was
completely unaware that
there had been a prisoner of war camp
just a few kilometers away from his home
just two decades previously and that
issue was not addressed at school
parents didn't talk about that chapter
he said and so this is just one of the
examples where
he criticized germans for not paying
enough attention to that
really painful chapter in their history
and
to be honest that he said that the
remembrance didn't change until a few
years ago
the attention paid to the eastern
victims of the nazi past
until german reunification and since
then germany has tried to better
integrate the commemoration of those
atrocities into the collective
remembrance of the nazi past
but of course it is difficult to deal
with and of course sometimes it does
lead to diplomatic tensions also because
the geopolitical map has changed
compared to what it looked like 80 years
ago
and there are now conflicts between some
of the countries that used to belong to
the same block to the soviet union if
you take the military conflict between
russia and ukraine for example
or the fact that the baltic states um
some of them have now
they have now joined the european union
and so in fact today's event was also
overshadowed by that conflict between
russia and ukraine
before the event the ambassadors of 7
out of 15 of the countries
that are now the successes of soviet
republic said that they would boycott
today's events
because they say germany is not
differentiating enough and for
that germany equates the soviet union
too often with what
is modern russia modern-day russia alone
so is that gonna change then what
concrete actions is germany taking
well it is baby steps of course and like
i say the process did start after
germany unification
and high-ranking politicians in germany
have tried to start by actually going to
those places going to those prisoner of
war camps
president steinmeier himself was foreign
minister before he became president and
in that position
he was for example he was the first
german politician to actually
commemorate the victims in belarus
on a trip there um to the biggest
concentration camp
during soviet occupation that is uh
located near minsk and that history
completely risked to be forgotten so
steinmeier
kept going to those places he went to
volgograd as well where he met with war
veterans
and germany politicians are now saying
in their speeches
that it was part of the nazi's official
plan to kill the population
in the east and get rid of entire
nations that way
uw's political correspondent nina hazard
there thank you nina
you